il y avait aussi Karine Le Marchand
tiens elle a affirmé une nouvelle fois
son soutien à Stéphane Plazza on va en
parler dans un instant de Stéphan Plazza
tu peux récupérer tes petites fiches là
euh ce dernier étant accusé de violence
conjugale des faits qu'il conteste bien
entendu on regarde et on en parle
ensemble regardez partir sans vous poser
une question sur Stéphane Plaza accusé
de violence et de menace par trois
ex-compagnes vous vous continuez à le
soutenir publiquement c'est mon ami il y
a une justice c'est important que la
justice aille plus vite pour ce genre
d'affairire pour les femmes qui ont subi
des des maltraitances et c'est important
que la justice aille plus vite pour les
personnes qui estiment qu'elles sont
accusées à tort et toujours votre
meilleure ami fait partie de mes
meilleurs amis oui oui alors oui c'est
c'est c'était une belle déclaration
surtout queelle l'avait déjà plus ou
moins défendu dans Paris Match hein où
où elle avait dit qu'il avait été
victime de enfin effectivement qu'il
avait eu une une grosse altercation avec
la fameuse jade que ça avait été violent
mais qu'en aucun cas il était un homme
violent d'ailleurs elle avait dit à la
la limite c'est un con un gouja mais je
ne l'ai jamais vu violent rarement en
colère donc en fait voilà elle prend à
nouveau sa défense faut quand même
savoir que Karine l mararchand c'est une
très très grande amie de Stéphane Plaza
elle a toujours été là pour lui à la
mort de sa mère en 2016 quand il a eu
des problème d'alcool elle a également
été là ils partent en vacances
régulièrement ensemble et c'est vrai que
l'enquête avance ou pas alors l'enquête
pour l'instant elle est un peu en
standby alors il y a il y a eu deux
plaintes pour pour violence sur conjoint
qui ont été déposé Stéphane Plaz
lui-même pe porter plainte pour
harcèlement il y a trois plaintes de
femmes qui ont été contactées par les
victimes présumé qui ont également porté
plainte pour l'instant Stéphane Plaza
n'a pas été convoqué par la police donc
c'est toujours en suspens pour l'instant
ça avance assez lentement quand même
très bien donc lentement alors il y a
Laurent rier aussi qui avait défendu he
Laurent je prends toujours ce ce genre
de choses avec beaucoup de pincettes on
a vu des tas d'affaires du même genre
qui ont été contredites ensuite par les
intéressés ou elles-mêmes il faut
laisser Stéphane tranquille pour pour
qu'il puisse se défendre de ses
accusations je n'ai aucun doute sur sa
probité oui il y a aussi Sophie verjani
qui a pris celle qui co anime avec lui
des émissions qui a pris sa défense et
qui et qui s'en prend même assez de
façon assez assez assez violente aux
femmes en disant regardons ces femmes
qui se sont ligués contre Stéphane pour
faire plus de buzz avoir plus de
visibilité et en tirer certainement
quelques profit donc donc voilà c'est
une il a plein de copines qui le
défendent je sais et euh et toujours M6
bien sûr qui défend toujours Stéphane
plazin ver dévie pas de sa ligne pour le
moment il reste à l'antenne euh fidélité
à Stéphane Plazza et c'est vrai que la
plainte qui a été déposée contre les
plaignantes si je puis dire enfin euh
est une sorte de contrefeu qui sert
Stéphane Plaza parce que ça pourrait
pourrait euh non pas discréditer mais
atténuer la portée des victimes des
présumé victimes on va parler de gérardo
pard dans un instant mais juste avant ce
weekend c'était l'Eurovision Junior et
c'est une jeune française qui a gagné
elle s'appelle Zoé closure elle a 13 ans
on regarde sa prestation je connais
bien mon cœur bat en rythme il palpite
si vite quand je chante pour
toi non cœur bat en
Ry non cœur B
TR pour
[Musique]
toi va trop
vite non c va trop vite
je chante pour
[Applaudissements]
toi c'était pas mal hein pas mal après
il y a une histoire là je sais pas quoi
de je sais pas c'est contre le
harcèlement ouais ouais mais il y a un
bail chelou je crois on va en parler
demain je crois je je sais plus quand là
ouais ouais il a une journaliste qui m'a
appelé m'a ah vous êtes davantage au
courant que oui bah c'est
heureusement problème c'est le en tout
cas sur sur l'Eurovision Junior on est
très fort ça fait gagah
ouaisionovision junior on peut le gagner
c'est rien organis c'est pas comme comme
l'autre on a les images de la victoire
de Zoé bravo bravo Zoé on va
[Applaudissements]
regarder je suis hy cont
meroup
[Applaudissements]
on va
l'équiper afin qu'elle puisse n faire
revivre ce moment avec l'ensemble de ses
compatriotes qui avait gagné qui avait
gagné l'an
dernier deux fois suite gag c'est fou ça
il y a Gabriel qui qui a félicité zo je
crois qu' était je sais pasù il éta bah
là derrière làah ouais tu as raison et
ben voilà ben c'est comme ça
elle a gagné devant l'Espagne et
l'Arménie voilà bon on arrive à
remporter l'Eurovision Junior ça sert à
[Rires]
quoi savoir c'est sympathique sympa
c'est gamin qui chante voilà ok très
bien merci c'est c'est du divertissement
quand j'auris une question intéressante
je sais que je peux me tourner vers vous
c'est que vous êtes toujours là pour
vraiment pour m'éguiller était sur notre
plateau pour donner sa version des faits
dans l'affaire cé jeudi dernier
aujourd'hui nous avons des nouvelles de
de Sébastien l'animateur a porté plainte
pour tentative d'extorsion de fond et
déénonciation calomieuse petit récap et
on en parle avec myiam
palombarass depuis plus d'un mois
l'animateur Sébastien cé est visé par
les témoignages de plusieurs femmes
l'une d'elles a même porté plainte pour
viol contre lui il a détruit ma famille
il m'a détruit moi aussi mais alors que
l'homme qui a été écarté de l'antenne de
énergie ni depuis le début les
accusations dont il fait l'objet j'ai
les preuves de mon innocence je me
battrai contre cette lamentable
entreprise de déstabilisation ses
avocats viennent de faire savoir à
travers un communiqué qu'une plainte
notamment pour dénonciation calomnieuse
et tentative d'extorsion de fond en
bande organisée a été
déposé alors bonsoir myiamam ça a été ce
weekend super qu'est-ce que fait
quelqu'un de très rasser le
weekend elle fait quoi non mais tu
cherches des rass la recherche de r
ouais je fais que ça regarde
la panade et je dis ça ça va bien ok
très bien ma chérie dis-moi tout oui
alors qu'est-ce que tu fais là alors ce
soir on a on a énormément de de dossiers
r ouais c'est vrai tu m'as écrit
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure ouais ouais
ouais c'était c'est assez énorme donc on
commence par cohé commence par qui tu
veux me fais pas chier d'accord alors cé
alors on dit que la défense la meilleure
défense c'est l'attaque donc calme-toi
démarre pas comme ça tout le temps tu es
insupportable donne les FA AR don t
c'est pas méchant cétait écrit ça c'est
pas
méchant don c'est pas méchant la
première chose qu'il fait donc là il va
après avoir porté plainte pour j'ai rien
fait non j'ai rien fait après avoir
après avoir porté PL connais pour
harcèlement et et dénonciation calomieux
ces avocats ont ont lancé un un comment
s'appelle un communiqué de presse
aujourd'hui où ilattaquent pour dire
qu'ils attaquent aujourd'hui ils ont
déposé plaines pour tentative
d'extorsion de fond en bande organisé
dénonciation calomnieuse faux et usage
personne contre personnes non dénommé tu
comprends ce que tu dis ou judique force
qu'est-ce qu' qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
Gill s'il te plaît monsieur non c'est
une contre-attaque très vive sur le plan
judiciaire parce que ça veut dire qu'ils
estiment que les accusations contre
Sébastien cohet encore une fois je donne
leur version sont orchestrés euh
tentative d'extorsion en bande organisé
euh en gros avec un but financier il
parl de calomnie orchestré c'est-à-dire
qu'ils estiment que derrière cette
plainte se cacherait j'emploie des mots
prudents hein évidemment se cacherait
une tentative de plusieurs personnes
pour extorquer de l'argent euh à
Sébastien cohet et lui nuire cette
démarche judiciaire soulligne la gravité
de la situation et répond à la calomnie
orchestrée pour gravement porter
atteinte à l'honneur et à la réputation
de notre client avec un but financier
dissimulé c'est ça que je voulais que
vous liez depuis tout à l'heure donc je
vais le faire
moimmême ou on a dit avec des pruv as
raison tu as raison chérie avec des
preuves avec des preuves matérielles
pertinentes disIl c'est-à-dire qu'ils
vont apporter les preuves de ce qu'ils
dénoncent sur le front judiciaire voilà
reste maintenant à avir l'autre partie
et évidemment le camp adverse Cyril mais
c'est une très vive contre-attaque
judiciaire et puis aussi ce qui est
important c'est que comme il y a eu des
SMS qui ont été dévoilés sur Twitter et
que ces SMS pour eux n'ont pas été
identifiés pour pour la pour l'équipe de
coé l'équipe d'avocat de coé ce sont des
des mensonges ce sont des faux SMS et
c'est justement ça qu'ils vont essayer
d'apporter comme preuve aujourd'hui
d'accord d'autres choses oui oui non sur
c'eston sur cé on attend il est toujours
pas revenu sur énergie non toujours pas
euh toujours pas il y a l'enquête
interne qui est qui est toujours en
cours sur sur la radio et puis puis la
jeune femme a déposé ses deux plaintes
le 18 et 20 novembre pour viol sur
mineur de de de plus de 15 ans et viol
pour des faits qui remontent à l'année
dernière très bien oui et sur la partie
extorsion de fonds et et but financier
on a eu accès à des des des preuves et
des témoignages qui montrent que la
jeune femme a fait appel à des conseils
ce qui est normal hein et des avocats en
demandant combien elle pourrait retirer
financièrement à coé donc c'est la
théorie de la défense de ce qui dit
qu'il y aurait un but financier avant
même l'idée de de d'avir même l'effet il
y aurait un but financier voilà ça
appuie ces proposl très bien merci en
tout cas de de de de cette petite info
alors on a le test de culture générale
des m-fance tiens qui vient d'arriver
euh tiens je vous je vais vous le faire
un petit peu tiens vous êtes chez vous
pour voir si vous pourriez être Miss
France vous aussi vous qui nous regardez
même mon qui attend son
jogging par ex il y a des questions donc
c'est quel pays a intégré la zone euro
cette année la Croatie le montenégro ou
l'Ukraine quoi c'est vrai dans quel pays
se déroulera la prochaine Coupe du monde
de rugby Afrique du Sud Australie
Argentine australieral bien sûr euh bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr je
pourrais pas être Miss France l'année
2024 est synonyme de jeux olympiques
quelle Miss France sera l'ambassadrice
du relais de la femme olympique au côté
de Thomas Pesquet Jamel Debou et Thierry
Marx iris mer marine lorfelin ou
Amandine petit marine l'orphelin
exactement voilà donc c'est c'est c'est
chiant
euhésa pas c'est chiant quelle est la
capitale du Brésil tiens Brasilia Rio de
janiro Brasilia bien sûr quel pays
appton le pays du soleil le vent la
Corée du Sud la Chine ou Japon oui et
vos
gueules quelle cérémonie récompense le
monde de la musique aux États-Unis les
Golden Glob les
baft gramyard exactement quel artiste
est l'auteur de cette célèbre affiche du
Moulin Rouge Picasso Toulouse autrec ou
Manet
Toulous la répseant con la Goul vous don
la réponse avant on pas on va pas y
arriver ah ouais voilà donc voilà donc
c'est ça donc il y a plein de questions
ah question tiens parmi ces propositions
lequel de ces animaux tue le plus
d'hommes chaque année l'hippopotame le
requin le lion
hippopotam c'est fou c'est fou c'est
fou c'est fou c'est fou c'est fou c'est
fou une autre question tiens ah pas mal
cette question tiens un croissant et une
chouquette coûte 200 2,10 € au total le
croissant coûte 2 € de plus que la
chouquette combien coûte la chouquette
il nous prennent pour des cons
10 10 non
non 25 + 05 font 2 c'est surtout que ça
existe pas vous faites exprès vous êtes
débil des chouettes je vous me défie de
ramener une chouette à 5 centimes
exactement moi aussi c'est 30 ctimes
tiens Nathan et Tom ont à de 64 ans
ouais sachant que Nathan et trois fois
plus âgé que Tom quel est l'âge de Tom
oh Mo même 64 je peux même pas réfléchir
16 16 ans ouais il a 16 ans il a 16 ans
cet HME là euh Ahou c'est pas il y a
plein de questions comme ça c'est pas
mal du tout votre médecin vous prcrit un
cachet à prendre toutes les demi-heur
combien de temps vous frida-t-il pour
prendre six cachés les dem 2h de 2h ou
cach 2h va prendre tes cachés nous fait
pas
chier tiens parce que j'ai l'abitude de
prendre des cachetes c'est pour ça que
je le sais merci
S c'est vraiment sympa de faire
l'émission avec toi euh ah dans le code
de la route est-il autorisé de
téléphoner au volant muni d'une
orillette oui non non non non non voilà
donc c'était les questions de de Miss
France ce test est donc noté sur 40
points les Miss ont également le droit à
une dictée et l'examen est donc noté sur
60 points sachez que le classement
numéro sont deux égalités il y a Miss
Roussillon Élise Aquilina et Agathe
toulieu Miss Limousin ils ont 40 40 sur
60 et celle qui a mieux réussi le truc
c'est Adeline V Miss Alsace et vous
savez pourquoi elle a dicté très bien
parce qu'en fait elles ont souvent
assigné les livres d'or dans province et
donc il faut qu'elle fasse pas trop de
fautes d'orthogp gros bisous c'est pas
dur à
écrire j'ai passé une excellente journée
fait une bonne
émissionis tiens l'animateur Stéphane
Bern était l'invité de àam samedi dans
quelle époque il en a profité pour
revenir sur son homosexualité plus
particulièrement sur l'homophobie dont
il est victime depuis toujours regardez
vous allez nous en parler après Patricia
avec vos parents ça a été difficile avec
votre mère notamment vous dites elle
préférait me voir mort plutôt
qu'homosexuel un jour elle m'a dit je
préfère te savoir mort qu'homosexuel je
lui dit bah ben ça va être difficile
j'ai vécu des trucs vous n'imaginez pas
vous n'imaginez pas ce qu'on peut vivre
on en dit des bêtises vous lui avez
pardonné oui je pardonne j'ai j'ai tout
pardonné à mes parents non alors ouais
c'est assez c'était assez émouvant de de
de l'entendre alors c'était pas la
première fois he qu'il parlait de son
homosexualité puisqu'il a fait son
coming out en 2009 dans dans dans le
magazine Têtu il est est parti très
jeune de chez ses parents il est parti
très très jeune de chez ses parents à 17
ans bah ben justement parce que parce
que sa mère n'acceptait pas son
homosexualité comme il l'a dit elle
préférait le voir mort plutôt comomo
donc il a décidé de de de de quitter de
quitter sa famille et puis et puis en
même temps il le voit il a réussi à leur
pardonner c'est ça qui est assez assez
fort he il explique he on on est souvent
très aimant vers ses bourreaux on aime
toujours aussi ses bourreaux dit-il il
monte et en fait comme lui vient d'une
d'une famille très bourgeoise il
reconnaît quand même qu' grâce à eux il
a une très bonne éducation et que et que
finalement malgré tout bah il est il est
toujours enfin toujours en lien avec eux
très bien euh il est avec son compagnon
depuis combien temps Stéphan alors ça
fait plus de 2 ans c'est un c'est un
jeune alors c'estan bayeres voilà c'est
ça il c'est pas le fondateur du club de
rencontre le cercle de Socrate si si si
donc c'est un c'est un cercle un peu up
où en fait des des des il s'agit d'un
club privé ha de gamme permettant au
célibataires gay de faire des rencontres
amoureuses c'est ça c'est ça une parti
cl rever 10% de ses bénéfices
àassociation le refuge qui vient
a officialiser leur relation 2021 oui
merci c'est sympa que tu
viennes en fait c'était au cours de la
de la la Marche des fiertés qu's l'ont
officialisé ils avaient fait un post sur
Instagram et puis quelques mois plus
tard ils sont allés sur par image faire
une très belle série photo et c'était
c'était super parce que c'était la
première fois qu'un qu'un couple
homosexuel était en coup
bravo bravo